we are counting down to the neck to next
week's historic SpaceX launch in
coverage we're calling launch America
this will be the first liftoff of
American astronauts from US soil since
2011 exactly one week from today
Elon Musk's SpaceX will take two NASA
astronauts to the International Space
Station
this marks the dawn of a new era in
space travel the commercial age our mark
Strassmann introduces us to the
astronauts who will be on this mission
Doug Hurley their introduction deserved
to be splashy Bob bankin Bob Behnken and
Doug Hurley are SpaceX's inaugural crew
they'll launch in the company's reusable
rocket the Falcon 9 and command the
maiden voyage of its new spacecraft the
crew dragon all the way to the space
station
both men flew one space shuttles both
have traveled twice before to the space
station
Hurley piloted Atlantis there in 2011
final flight of the shuttle program and
you didn't know whether you'd fly again
or for whom I wasn't sure I wanted to
fly again to be quite honest with you
you're a NASA astronaut about to step
into a SpaceX capsule it's completely
different than what you would have ever
imagined yourself doing Hurley now 53
grew up in upstate New York he was an
athletic kid who went to Tulane colonel
Hurley is also a retired Marine and a
flight test pilot bankin is 49 born and
raised near st. Louis he has a PhD in
mechanical engineering from Caltech in
the Air Force colonel bankin was a
flight test engineer both joined NASA in
2000 they've been friends for two
decades I gotta believe that's a help I
think we're way past the polite stage in
our relationship I'm not looking for
romance from Doug I'm not looking for
surprises in our relationship he's
predictable in a way that over 20 years
I've built a model for him and I can
tell you what he's going to say as we go
forward and he can tell you what
gonna do based on just a hearing the
tone of my voice or seeing the look on
my face sort of a thing you know one
characteristic I think we have in spades
is we don't quit we don't give up and we
like a big challenge and by gosh we we
certainly got one they both met their
wives in the NASA astronaut class of
2000 bankin married Megan McArthur
Hurley married Karen Nyberg they're
great guys in 2009 MacArthur's robotic
skills helped prolong the life of the
Hubble Space Telescope
she and bankin have a six-year-old son
Theodore just try to talk to him as
normally as possible about you know this
is daddy's job this is mommy's job dad's
gonna go and launch on a rocket and go
to Space Station so that it's just kind
of a normal thing for him to absorb
Nyberg Hurley's wife has spent 180 days
in space including two trips to the
space station
the junior wife leave little notes for
each other apparently her hair is still
up there I get reports all the time
she's got long blonde hair and they are
still finding it the filters up there so
my wife also does what I do for a living
it's much much harder for me to BSR
about certain aspects again we have the
same problem
what does that like to be married to
other astronauts and launching into this
new era of space exploration the biggest
thing is we know how they're gonna feel
on launch day and it is way harder on
them to watch somebody that you care for
get on a rocket and go fly than it is
for the two guys on the rocket it's a
tough tough job to be the one watching
on launch day Hurley's son jack will be
watching he drew this picture of his
father spaceship he hasn't talked about
being scared or nervous he's talked
about how proud he is it was dad I don't
want to talk about being scared and
nervous either and have him pick up on
that they had all rather focused on
potential rewards for America as a
spacefaring country and his astronaut
dads I think the thing I'm most looking
forward to is being able to share this
experience with my son this will be
something completely new for him but to
talk to him from space and to talk to
him about the mission
after I come back I'm just excited for
him to be able to see it with his own
eyes and experience bankin and Hurley
get here to Kennedy Space Center this
afternoon they've both been in
quarantine since last Wednesday and both
ten-year-old Jack and six-year-old
theatres will also be here to watch
their dad's launch in person and that
should give them a new appreciation from
what dad and mom do for a living
Anthony yeah well mark what a great
story what a great story the two of them
have together the four of them really
when you include the wives and the whole
families we wish them all the best thank
you mark great great great story we'll
continue to count down to the SpaceX
launch on Wednesday May 27th right here
on CBS this morning
next week we'll talk to NASA astronaut
Christopher Cassidy who is on the
International Space Station waiting to
greet the SpaceX crew when they arrive